- En mettant la main sur
les 4000 films du studio MGM,
Amazon et son service de
visionnement frappent fort.
- Amazon ne cesse de frapper
des grands coups.
- Ça va obliger les autres
joueurs à se repositionner.
- Fondé en 1924,
le studio hollywoodien
Metro Goldwyn Mayer est
derrière de grands films comme
"Autant en emporte le vent",
"2001, l'Odyssée de l'espace"
et "Le magicien d'Oz"
HÉLÈNE FARADJI, critique cinéma
- Et là, avec l'achat de MGM,
ça devient un joueur majeur
de l'industrie audiovisuelle
nord-américaine en particuler.
- En achetant MGM pour la somme
de 8,45 milliards de dollars
américains, la plateforme de
visionnement Amazon Prime Video
obtient un catalogue important
de films, et entre autres
les franchises de "Rocky",
de "James Bond" et de la série
"Le servante écarlante".
BRUNO GUGLIELMINETTI, consultant
en services numériques
- C'est ça qui est important :
on met le grappin sur
des propriétés intellectuelles
et ça, ça vaut énormémment
d'argent.
MICHEL COULOMBE, critique cinéma
- "Rocky", on peut ressortir ça
à tout moment il y aura toujours
un prétexte; et "James Bond",
c'est inusable.
La preuve : il y a un nouveau
film à l'automne.
- La pandémie avait fait mal
aux studio comme MGM, mais
elle a bénéfié aux service
de visionnement comme
Amazon Prime Video, qui a près
de 200 millions d'abonnés
à travers le monde.
DESTINY TCHEHOUALI, professeur,
comm. sociale et publique, UQAM
- Et là, cela affiche très
clairement les ambitions
d'Amazon de rivaliser
avec Netflix. Les stratégie
qu'on voit à l'oeuvre
actuellement, stratégie fusion,
hyper concentration...
- Qu'est-ce que
cette transaction veut dire
pour l'avenir du cinéma?
Un modèle hybride s'impose
de plus en plus.
- Je ne pense pas que le cinéma
en salle va mourir, mais
je pense qu'on va distribue
moins de films, on va faire
un tri.
- Amazon est en train de
nous dire : comptez avec nous,
craignez-nous. C'est ce qu'à
fait Disney en 2020 et c'est
ce que fait Amazon en 2021.
- Comme dans un film
d'espionnage, la compétition
entre les géants du visionnement
en ligne est pleine
de rebondissements et
de plus en plus féroce.
- Hasta la vista, baby!
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.